hello
okay we did it
nothing like dropping 5 000 viewers so
you could restart your pc huge bummer i
did have a windows update though so i'm
actually gonna guess that was my problem
um hi everyone i'm alana
welcome dude my first time playing
cyberpunk 2077 the stream is sponsored
by nvidia
um kind of in partnership with nvidia
because they gave me a 3080 that um
i just installed and played around with
um i'm so stoked about it because i
absolutely really wanted one and it's
been really hard to get um on twitch
we've installed night uh
nightbot is that it a chatbot for the
first time ever where if you do the
exclamation point at a g-force
i also put my social media in there
because i thought it was cute and i
didn't know what else to do with it
so that's about it yeah it works
so cool um but yeah i'm basically gonna
be showing you guys
ray tracing and dlss um
[Music]
that's the idea there's showing it off
which is the thing obviously i would do
anyway
which i'm very excited about so
just want to make sure one more thing is
working
it is okay let's do it
uh i'm going to tap out of there
i am going uh no mad
because i'm in the nomad playthrough but
also that i feel like it works for the
first playthrough
um because
i want to be an outsider at a night city
and then i think i'm going to do a
copper and then i'm going to do a street
kit
i definitely plan to be playing this
game for a long time for the record i am
playing on
what is technically a beta version i
don't know if it's actually called that
uh but this does not have the day one
patch
um it is not the full version of the
game just yet
okay we want to go feminine yeah
and then we're gonna do this
no i was gonna say i promise i won't
take too long here but it's just a lie
it's just a lie um
i feel like i like that okay hairstyles
does that say that there are 35 of them
i feel like i knew that but now i'm
scared okay geez
oh the pressure oh geez there are 39
hairstyles
oh gosh oh audio again sorry
yeah i see i see i see you how is that
you guys have game audio
yeah you good okay
dude who just
all caps said do you like [__]
hey you want to talk about [__] we can
do that i have no problem with doing
that where is it where is it
this is so big i knew that already i've
seen this before but oh my god look at
it okay here we go
see here we go genitals
you asked for it now it's going to be
there the whole time then i go through
the rest of the character creator okay
it's your fault you did that i didn't do
that
see i like that but
i feel like i can find something i like
more you know you know
i'm gonna try not to spend too long here
i promise that's cool too what are you a
padawan
that one is really good so uh 11
remember 11.
that's me when i was 13 100
you want to listen to my chemical
romance in your spare time
see i like these ones as well though i
feel like it suits it
um
that's pretty cool
i'm still partial to 11 though
that's my hair that's just 100 my hair
a thought has occurred that could
actually be my hair
you know that actually could be the hair
that they
used when they made me in the game
right
let me look at my picture hang on i'm
like because i feel like it's not that
different like that could
literally actually be my hair in the
character creator
it totally is oh my god
when i oh my god that's so cool
that i like jump into this and i'm like
that looks pretty similar to my hair
it's because it [__] is my hair like
that's that's so cool um
i would just like you all to know that
hairstyle 31
was literally from pictures of my face
okay i'm not doing it though that would
be narcissistic and ridiculous
but holy [__] that's cool oh my god
amazing okay uh or it could be that one
i suppose
could be either could be either but i'm
taking ownership of it
all right we're going 11. um as cool as
all of that is we are going with
11 because i thought it was neat
okay see that doesn't look like the
color you're telling me it is
i always want to go with a white um
which has got to be that which i still
don't feel like is quite
right but maybe under different lighting
it'll look different
okay
what kind of vibe do i want you to have
you know like
what are you about v um i should have
paid attention to that i like that
it's aggressive you know or tired can
relate
i think it was one of the early ones
that i liked
i'm cool with this one
there's attitude in six
just two elevens okay cool
eye color it's always gotta be purple
eyebrows
gosh dang even got no brows
one two three
eight of them
this one yeah eyebrows could be dark
love
you can't be walking around with
see-through eyebrows that's ridiculous
who do you think you are do you think my
nose is part of the character karina
that seems unlikely
but if it is it's no no i could maybe
find it
i like that though that's cute okay
mouth
give you some lips
beautiful we like 13. so much gloss on
her just natural
natural gloss thank you hannah i agree
she's turning out cute so far
hmm
what was it 13 i think i just pulled
that number out of thin air
we like 10.
[Music]
it was 13. okay i like it
well i think 10 is better actually this
is the problem
is that i do this for my whole life i
can do this my whole life okay jaw huh
that seems good
[Music]
let's change a new holding face okay
12 is nice yeah let's do 12.
yes 14 pairs of ears
oh my gosh okay
[Music]
i don't know what makes a good ear that
seems good you can hear a lot
cyberware yes king
[Music]
no no no not off what what what what
what is it currently not available
because i would like a lot of it damn
you
okay um i always do a scar
over the eye that's a bit much
oh but you can get them like face
tattoos
[Music]
uh people in chat yes i'm allowed to
stream the game 12 hours prior
for those asking how technically there
are a lot of reasons why i'm allowed to
do it um but the most interesting one is
that i
worked on slash i'm in the game i'm in
the credits
but there are a lot of other reasons
like obviously this stream is in
partnership with nvidia he gave me a
3080 so i can show you guys ray tracing
when we get out of here
i like that facial tattoos
okay
that's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life what are you joking
i think that's pretty neat would you
just
upload the top of your head
oh love's a neck hat i wish it weren't a
flower though
born to kill i think i'm gonna go with
the barcode
okay piercings huh geez
i think i'm gonna go without we're gonna
have no piercings
that does look nice though
but you don't need them
you don't need them no now now i think
that now i'm thinking that you do
i'm sorry everyone
i like it okay piercing color
it's just that i i think yeah show me
your chompers
we're just getting our regular old teeth
okay eye makeup
that's beautiful you're a babe
whoa cool um
yeah that's pretty that's pretty rad
that's pretty rad you look cool as hell
i feel like i should have looked through
them more
but i have all this pressure because i'm
streaming that i'm like worried that i'm
not going through the character creator
fast enough but i am going to play this
like this this whole time so
i'm sorry everyone you got to deal with
it i like it
lip makeup
[Music]
off my gosh
i'm like halfway
yeah fine without blemishes
i can't even really see what you're
doing to me here
nails oh that's right i forgot she was
naked i forgot that she was naked
uh okay
sure
i like that one they said to be careful
with your nails
because you're gonna see them for a long
time
i just i feel like that that makes sense
okay just like
yeah probably like just
i don't know that i'd call that big but
i guess we're gonna go with big
nipples my gosh
um i've never had to do this to someone
and i feel
mean like i feel like that looks
proportionate
i like to there a lot
i'm gonna go with two
uh the stream won't be monetized anyway
you guys i'm not worried about that uh
thankfully youtube not being
my uh source of income means i don't
have to worry about that kind of stuff
so i'm actually uh i can go
off
well i'm just gonna go with a nice
vagina
that's a high public i don't feel like
they should go up that far
a landing strip am i gonna turn that off
and
i'm scared but i think i think
that's it
why didn't the cyberware work is what i
want to know
oh well maybe i just didn't hit it right
i think she looks cool as hell
hmm which one do i want like i liked
those first two the most
i'm gonna let you choose chat which
which one uh one or two
one or two some ones in there
i feel like you're mostly saying well
it's really all over the place
hey nobody said you could pick four get
out of here with that
i have no way of telling
which one you're mostly picking because
it seems to be
all over the place
i think that y'all are saying
just gonna say two but now it looks like
it's one
i think if we also if we include both i
think we're doing one
[Music]
okay
so this is this is a thing that i should
have thought about beforehand
i think we want tech and intelligence
i do love health
i don't want to go with mealy weapons
but you know i love health um i feel
like i want to specialize in two is a
thing that's cool
crit damage resistance and stealth
damage no that's it then isn't it
so big ram i don't care that much about
that technical
i think it's these two that i want to do
and we'll throw one in body
i feel good about it
my gosh we've done it
my gosh let's go let's go let's go don't
know if it's delayed but it looks like
you guys are still spamming which one i
should pick even though i'm way out of
character greater
i think it might be because it's because
of slow mode
that would make sense um okay
so as soon as i get into the game we
will turn on them ray tracings thanks to
my 4080.
shout out to nvidia
i love her yeah i would die for you
oh i'm gonna play with my controller now
electric coupling module
so i've not played the um you said you
were sure
the nomad intro um so this will be my
first time doing this too
which is super exciting
so let's go to my settings
and make sure it's probably best done
this way
but everything is the way that we want
i feel like i want to turn the phone
right off but then we could always see
and i want some i should put it off
interesting contact shadow's on
i'm going to leave literally all of this
and i'm going to do
hello beautiful
i am very excited to trace those rays
you don't even know
medium sure we could play with it but
i'm just gonna say medium just in case
dls auto seems good
oh my gosh let's do it
i don't think i need to change anything
else
no no no no okay
it's on let's roll
you can always look for another shop
where they won't ask a low nomad while
she's hugging the border
see here's the cool thing about ray
tracing ladies and gentlemen that they
don't like
you know i'm sure loads of people know
this i'm not gonna pretend like it's new
information on anyone
however um there's one thing that i
really like about ray tracing that i
feel like doesn't get as much love is
the way it diffuses light
it's like a natural light diffusion
instead of it
basically if i turn this off i mean i
could just do it can i
i always always only wrote one if we go
back to graphics and then down and we
turn it off
off and then i go just
back this should be
a significantly harsher light because
that took too long i actually can't tell
but it does make light diffusion a lot
prettier i mean you can see that it
looks like a little bit strange
anyway basically rtx is cool um
you can use the chat bot to
uh back on baby
um get more information about that but
yeah
just the see see the difference that
made to that poll
you love to see it
no audio are you sure about that i think
you're lying
yeah that person's gotta be lying but um
yeah i hope you saw that um i could play
with mac settings at some point but uh
i'm not gonna do that oh hang on hang on
hang on there are other settings that i
need to change
the the
sound setting the streamer mode is in
here somewhere right
uh disable copyrighted music that would
probably be it let me check the
the email from cdpr to make sure that
i've done the right thing here
i assume that's all i had to do
that's it beautiful i love that they've
done that it's so
it's so awesome um so handy probably
should have done it earlier because that
song could have just completely screwed
me
but here we are okay
cool uh game audio is low
let me just turn it up then there you go
it's the weirdest habit of playing on pc
and console like quite frequently i like
swap between all platforms is that i
always want to do menu stuff on a mouse
and keyboard i don't know why
okay hi let's play the video game
that's fine step aside what
got any idea what to do frankly i have
absolutely
no clue what to do i'm going to bypass
the coupling
i'm glad she does compress on and off
here
did anyone
i just kind of want to look around a bit
first though you know this is the thing
that really impressed me the first time
i played the game
is um
how much detail there is in just like
the back
environments oh what's this
documents you say
it is an rpg ladies and gentlemen gotta
remember that
okay okay
let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you me a second
um yeah look i can change the settings
folks who are asking me to play on ultra
um i can
um and do not mind doing that in a
little bit
questions how long it'll last just
because when it crashed when i first
started detroit i'll figure something
else out there
trying not to stress it out too much
i'm looking for someone jackie wells
maybe maybe
so doable sure was
satisfying that not a solid face
satisfaction
duct tape it worked that's what matters
a human
oh it's the cops is here didn't know you
had a customer
rolled in a few hours passed i i thought
she'd at least called in to you don't
you swear to mine
we're gonna hash it out
anybody don't you know you owe the
sheriff a word when you pay his town a
visit
to tell him what's brought you here
maybe even over a cup of coffee
no need to worry i won't be staying long
didn't answer my question i wonder if
there's a purpose to the cyber wearing
their faces
i have uh andrew jones probably
intentionally like stayed away from
law i'm not going to reply to that
served in spec ops during the last war
um so i can play the game and then i'll
go do like a deep dive
ray tracing is on yes
[Music]
yeah i feel like you definitely should
have expected that
if you have a problem i'm willing to
hear it i don't know if i like the nails
now
the little pug nothing like a [__]
string
where'd your clan pitch camp
are you one of those i don't know much
about the nomads really despite
typically nomads are the world's
greatest i'm not playing with day one
patch no
i'm a man that respects order corpse
brought us that order
and i intend for it to stay there the
corpse pay you and have you on a leash
like a dog you know that
mm-hmm but you don't want to see me bear
my
face so i'll ask again i don't know sir
where's your clan i have no idea i'm
here alone
there's no camp i'm here alone
ain't behind it nomads always stick to
that i don't know anything about any of
this i just got here and inhabited this
body
what am i supposed to know makes you an
outcast among
outcasts sure as hell hope you'll be on
your way before long
yeah i can change the settings um i
can't put it full screen
instead of borderless windowed ziggy fix
because i'm streaming and i have a super
ultra wide monitor so i have to stream
everything in
1080 um and borderless window they have
to it's not a choice sadly
otherwise you will not be able to see
half the game
i saw a broadcast in coms tower on my
way in
my antenna is down and i need to radio
somewhere what you need just to hightail
it out of here without another word
ain't got no mind to see you drifting
around these parts
got it
we done did it cool i have not been in
the badlands before
look at the windows retracing ladies and
gentlemen the car
i just i love it i love it a whole lot
uh would it run on ultrawide if you
weren't streaming i imagine so but i
don't actually know i guess i'll find
out as soon as i
start playing um
in my own time immediately does not go
on the path
immediately for the record that was
vaguely intentional the crashing i just
want to be clear
i feel like this looks very nice
this is where i'm supposed to be anyway
gotcha
okay that car i don't feel like should
sound the way that it does
i can open it at any point in time
i mean it's pretty [__] detailed then
can i shoot the cop
um i'm honestly very impressed by
the way this crossing stuff looks um i
don't think i have a gun
so no
how is that even locked
by what i don't know
uh sure i can change i can change
settings
people would like i think that nvidia
sent me a suggestion so let me take a
look at those
um people are certainly complaining
about them so let's take
a look at what they suggested
there's a big old document uh
i already did that
[Music]
no it didn't really
there's your cyberpunk one sheet
my gosh ray tracing's beautiful just
so good
um
[Music]
no i mean they are suggesting that i i
do play
uh uh
in
because it because i have to do 1080 for
the purposes of the stream and i can't
output to 4k
to both platforms anyway they are
suggesting i do ultra
yeah okay if you say so
hey why's that happened oh gotta redo
everything that makes sense
let's see ultra and then dls we want to
be i want to do
auto for that okay
yeah i mean i feel like this looks great
for the record like it's i'm impressed
by how it looks
you know
look at the puddles you'd love to see it
okay
you want me to turn motion blur off okay
eventually we'll play the video game
wait wait did it not save is that what
you're telling me
no it did ah
i'm cool with auto um what do you want
me to change oh uh
uh the motion blur completely off
and i wanted to send film right off cool
okay
oh night city yeah
okay i expected that to be a climb
ladder button but there wasn't
you can just push up on the stick
i've played far cry i know how this is
going to go you're going to let me
zipline down
all right are you jacked
i don't even know why she's trying to
find jackie right now
hello come in come in
raised to finally willie mccoy
it's good to hear your voice okay i do
like the nails good news
wish i could say the same
i need your help one last time
one last time again i have to find the
client with my payload
but i i don't know where he is
right thank you jack i appreciate that
people's yelling at me changing things
come on
just let me play the game of course i
was i will accommodate the client left a
message
um jenna's i'm not playing with the day
one patch no hmm
sure last time though i mean
actually left a message he's waiting on
a farm
flicking you the globe data thanks
willie
i owe you one you do just don't get
yourself
killed and don't call again
okay bye
again the ray tracing thing's gonna
sound really stupid to anyone who
doesn't understand how much i love ray
tracing and the fact that i only just
got it this week
so and my monitor is beautiful
there's a rainbow i'm like dude
yes
okay
it's a lot quieter out here than i
expected but i suppose we are
effectively in the middle of nowhere
the lighting you just love to see it
you just love to see it
oh my gosh um again yeah if you guys
want to get
details um put the exclamation point i
did the
the g-force because i set up a chatbot
for the first time ever to find out more
information from nvidia
who hooked me up with 3080 for this
play with that sensitivity you're right
no zip line
devastatingly no zip line
um it is not far cry turns out
well you know i could go that way or i
could just go this way we just go around
what happens if i run into a tree let's
can we just try that what happens to
them
crumbled that cactus how about you
destroyed absolutely destroyed
done get out of here
i kind of just want to walk around so
that's what i'm going to do
hey what are you up to
just hanging out having a good time
drinking your
calavera
is this some kind of sex trailer
it might be you know it might be
yeah uh what i know you no i'm sorry
my apologies i really got all up in a
[__]
okay
i just i'm just out here trying to see
what the town looks like you know
i like it a lot
um yeah so you guys are probably
for the record getting my output
settings for the stream
are probably not as high as what i'm
seeing
what do i what am i at
streaming
uh because i just changed my graphics
card um i actually don't know
because it was previously on my amd card
but that is probably a thing
for the record i may not be streaming
um i can put it at 60 yes
settings that's going to be in video
well i'm going to change the field of
view a little bit i don't know that i
needed to do quite that much
we could do that film grain i think
should be off but it wanted it to be on
so i don't know i don't know
on yes all of this is high all of this
is good
retracing yes all of this seems good uh
video
and then we'll go 60 70 is probably the
ideal because that will
cap that way uh
that seems good
and this is the last time i'm going
through the menus you guys
last time i'm doing it there's anything
else you want
please tell me
obs output settings won't work if i'm at
kilobytes a second because i stream on
both
i would love to just play the game but
people keep yelling at me turn off film
green
okay that's okay it's off anything else
this is the last time i'm doing it
i swear to god
why are you using a controller um i'm of
the impression that the game was
designed from a controller
why 1080 uh because um
that's the way that my stream setup kind
of has to work
uh streaming on multiple platforms and
all that
uh i do have
dlss on
i already answered y1080 that's for
streaming purposes
and
done okay i'm not doing it again
i don't like to suffer view as much but
whatever you asked for it
hey buddy everybody out here smokes huh
hola how you doing just hanging out
they i love that they all look very
different it's a thing that i've always
said about
uh the games like the first times that i
played it
oh are these people gonna give me quests
used to drive rigs
i don't wanna fight you
hey bud i told you to disappear they
don't test my no that's fair
can i go inside this building i can
hey man don't cross the sheriff better
off doing what he says
that's fair
that's going to be locked i didn't know
if i'd be able to go in here
i guess i can oh my god ray tracing oh
my gosh
so good
can i go in any of the trailers i don't
know
um i don't know if locked means i
probably yeah i probably
can't go into all of them because why
would you but
if i want to go into any one of them
it'd be this one
devastating that's the saddest thing
that's ever happened to me i want to
know what's in the plus 18 love trailer
you know you know what i'm saying
excuse me okay
let's get in shall we
[Music]
i thought that town looked great
am i going to meet jackie right now is
that what i'm doing
i think i am and i wonder how much like
stuff there is out
here you know it is an rpg ladies and
gentlemen
like is there gonna be is it gonna be
loot if i explore out here
don't mind me just gonna look around a
little bit
um
yeah everything seems to be in order
you got stuff for me is this
theft technically it's mine now
honestly i think this looks beautiful
i think this looks really good uh
and i don't know why i'm so like
surprised by it but again
maybe it's just the fact that i just got
ray tracing but like
yeah no i think this game looks looks
great worried i'd have to turn to
farming
hi jackie yeah sure hope you're here for
me oh why are you guys
gonna you got your gun right now you
gotta seem necessary to you
so wells and jackie
seems you have cargo that needs to be
moved oh where i'm from you share a bit
about your soul before you talk biz
how do you it's kind of like used to the
toilet
or just good manners you know
start with you why don't we start with
you then this jacket nc native right
here
got haywood in my mind it looks really
good never been to nc
that doesn't mean much to me so imagine
a place where everyone's like your bro
or sis or a distant cousin at least
i think i think he's from the door you
don't have to like each other it's a
mini game
uh yeah it is always going to be
compressed on the stream and again i'm
i'm outputting in 1080p
yes um you could say i'm from my own
hayward
you and me uh so that my computer
doesn't die
um and i don't just run my internet but
oh hey rude
i love that that bumped me back though
that was cool
um what's inside what's inside
you sleep better the less you know got
no idea myself and that's a good thing
you don't know what we aim to smuggle
these are stolen corporates i don't know
what's inside stolen
oh some gunk lost the crate some other
gunk found it passed it on
now it's here you know butterfly effect
or whatever
and there is no one looking for this
crate ain't no problem if they look i
know it's in the crate
only a problem if they find it before it
crosses the border no
let's load it in the car yo what this oh
it will yes
cards you say is this going to be some
kind of gwent i think they said they
didn't have anything like that in the
game
i'm taking everything it's an rpg i got
held up
and you weren't exactly easy to find i
decided to lay low you know
i'm gonna read through those at some
point
yep is tv's broken is that what that is
also i think like
his trailer is like the same size as my
apartment it might be
bigger it is bigger living in luxury my
dude
okay
oh yeah i gotta open the trunk can't
just drive away
we headed to night city i don't remember
because uh i've spoke to a a journalist
friend
stunning um about this life path
do you have the manifest from the
transition nice
as it turns out we can that was
beautiful
we're both professionals
[Music]
well uh i'm sure i can come back out
here
i would want to explore everything order
crossing up my head
what now nothing they'll scan us and
check
our papers driving feels um improved
from the last time i played it feels
good
oops hello
yeah okay cool please direct your
vehicle to the inspection
i'd love to i thought you'd never ask
remain in your vehicle the security
check will begin
shortly i got a reason about this do the
vehicles take damage i don't remember
i don't remember
uh yes hand me the manifest they'll need
to see it
detailing inside of this car let me see
ah it's mark delaway perfect what's that
mean
lost on arrival means the cargo was
flagged as to be lost as soon as it
crossed the border
so they know we're smuggling well
they're about to find out
the owner of the vehicle in the
inspection area will report for further
questioning
am i the owner of the vehicle i guess i
am
what now relax
it's all in line with procedures it's
all part of the plan
i guess you know what you're doing huh
i'm so happy to be playing this
okay if we want the customs officer to
turn a blind eye to our dubious docks
we'll need a sweetener
do you have the credit chip with the
bribe oh yeah
forgot about that
right you forgot oh that's right
everything's like
chips and that
if you're armed place your weapon here
just like
i don't know man look obviously
tremendous amount of bias
you know i've always owned that about
this game but like
just very impressed by these
environments
just
all of this is like everyone looking so
different
i don't know
oh i did have a gun
now please report to room number two
okay
is will you gonna take my semen samples
please sit
okay hello
papers
i know the rules everything's there it
might be
it might not be we'll see what is eyes
what are you transporting it's all in
there
everyone smokes my gosh
everything
there's one additional enclosure to the
manifest
his hands look cool ah yes remind me you
drive for which nomad clan
i don't drive for any clan i think
that's the actual answer no clan i drive
for myself
bold and none too wise
you know whenever i see someone like you
i'm oh so grateful not to be on that
side of the table
that's rude the feeling's mutual
go on now your associate's waiting for
you in the car
i like him i think he's cool
i'm just gonna look around and take your
personal items i didn't give you any
personal items whoa
what are you guys chatting about
bribes and stuff
this game looks great
[Music]
well i played street kid before so
that's the main difference uh but when i
played
last time obviously it was streamed from
poland we were playing streams so
um
it just the quality is infinitely better
and when i get to play super ultra wide
and go like full 4k and everything i'm
going to lose my mind
again this stream is sponsored by nvidia
for the record
um but in the most convenient
sponsorship ever and that
you know they they gave me a 30 80 to
check out the game and ray tracing which
is something that i would have done
anyway and i would have streamed it
anyway totally
yeah i'm extremely excited about so we
have ray tracing on
we have dlss on
and it is beautiful why are we going so
slow mate
we got places to be someone's coming our
way
this does not look good doesn't it
stop your vehicle immediately let's
am i supposed to shoot
here we go i was like i haven't actually
had any uh i need tutorial at any point
okay draw a weapon also weapon and
return to c double tap y
uh okay so i'm gonna immediately lean
out i
am
this doesn't seem like the right gun for
this job is all i'm saying
it does not seem like the right no
one that was your head reload reload
reload
yes good good no no
who would have thought that driving and
shooting was difficult
jackie could you can we just drive in a
straight line i think we in a straight
line
stop okay that's fine
no i'm gonna take him oh too but i can't
see you oh there you are okay nope nope
nope we're good
okay
i'm into this oh wait no they're back
i'm sorry i'm sorry jackie i'm sorry i
like down oh
i feel like i'm not supposed to shoot
him i feel like this is going to be
scripted
yeah that's someone who's obscured by a
[Music]
vehicle
fully respect everyone who's like i
don't want to see it um
you don't want the game spoiled for you
totally here
well i mean you did that didn't he
i almost tagged our asses not what you
call smuggling
chicago that wasn't my fault supposed to
go smooth
no problem jackie if you think this is
my fault
at least have the balls to say so i
don't know yet
is it border security tipped off the
corporation that we have their cargo
what's the deal with these borderleafs
flipping us a finger as they [__]
please
with no consequences he took a risk he
assumed we didn't have a clan
backing us and he was right
so what now
i could ask you the same question will
you keep whining or will we put a bow on
this thing
i ain't gonna lie i'm a bit like
brilliant jackie brilliant
now and you just ranted at me are you
kidding me once i collect my scrap for
this corporal crap we're carrying it oh
and you just
figured i would sit by patiently
actually i wasn't gonna be you at all
just gonna bust ass and disappear as
soon as we crossed over
i do love him you're all right
i appreciate the honesty yeah thanks
so what's next now we take a peek inside
i think it's an animal if i remember oh
i'm inside of you jackie i'm sorry about
that that must have felt very violating
my apologies good sir
okay oh she's like an iguano or
something
says arasaka on the crate we are robbing
some heavy hitters
maybe we'll make some heavy money
a real iguana a uh lesser angelian i
think
you're iguanas that is kind of
unexpected yeah on tv about them
went extinct like 30 years ago they're
from the lesser antilles
anybody come a long way my scaly friend
is he breathing is he alive
think you can make some money on that
doesn't seem like a nice place for him
this is too big for the box
it'll make us happy us yeah partner
we'll go half season any decent fixer
will find a loaded gog interested in a
rare gem like this
he's kind of a shame though
like his neck everything moves you know
hey by the way
you uh got any plans for what you'll be
doing in nights hanging out
um i'm playing on a 3080. thank you for
getting that patrick i appreciate that
hello and yeah the
the stream i actually don't know what
fps i'm running the stream on but i
can't do too much with my my output
settings
um why do you ask why do you ask
because i got this feeling you got a lot
of time and nothing to spend it on
and then see in a city that lets you get
by without buddies
but don't you worry let me help you find
diggs
you got to live somewhere it's important
to have people you can turn to
you know like uh family maybe you'll
find your own don
are you asking me out thanks much
appreciate it
hey come on it's nothing you got
chemistry you and i do really like him
you're crying shame to waste it
i'm a fan of jackie partner hey oh
cuddly little [__]
happening um yeah okay partner
time to grab the lizard and scurry out
of here what that lizard looks
cool i'm into it this kind of looked
amazing
damn man this game's beautiful are you
kidding
me but i also recognize that i'm a big
old fangirl
oh i love this town love it like you
might love a mother who popped you out
on the steps of an orphanage once
and now stops you to ask you elected
every new day here means a hundred new
arrivals
but only half these gods will survive a
year and that's if it's a good one
and why do these peeps come to nc well
to be
street samurai like morgan blackhand and
waylon
[Music]
i just didn't expect this for some
reason um but i know that they said that
this this cutscene was
from what i played the um the preview
was missing there like will be a
cutscene here and i guess this is what
it is
the graveyard
matters not where you're from matters
not where you start
what matters here is
uh i'm thinking this is where the paths
converge
l gavin yes um
i believe that's the end of the prologue
but i'm not 100 percent obviously we're
looking for somewhere in this building
um
eyes and ears open all right it's a
little bit longer i'm not gonna witch
got you a little something another deck
training shard
okay so this part i have i have done i
did as um
in the streets again when i played the
prologue uh sorry the the preview event
so
uh yeah we're gonna do it ah jack we're
talking
nice accidentally skipping great tech
here how did you get it
debug and our girl made a couple
adjustments
why thinks she knows better i really
like her she
said it didn't suit her uh very cool
you'll see what i mean um
yeah sure why the hell not
she basically like modified a chip
so that you get the militech tutorials
but with
a twist let's begin with basic combat
training
this session will be recorded for
subsequent evaluations
uh yes mt as i
to use stealth am i agree with that
seattle boom i would have liked if i had
driven into the city then
i agree
and militech can't encrypt for [__]
but they clearly got drilling jar heads
in their blood i like her a lot
now controls astral plane yeah that's
true
move move move hope you're ready to bust
okay
i am ready to bust thank you for asking
november baby
okay you just you just want me to
shoot targets that's i think i can do it
i didn't think you'd find that too tough
what do you say we crank it up a notch i
do think i need to play with the
sensitivity though
it's uh a little bit too
not bad but it's more realistic if the
target's packing iron
cool put standing around and take cover
ah gotcha
you took a hit use a reanimator to patch
yourself up
i like that it's an inhaler
uh okay as an asthmatic i feel
represented
uh thank you for that patrick yeah for
everyone who's asking i'm running on an
rtx 3080.
the stream is sponsored by nvidia they
gave me the um
the 3080 so that i could show you guys
ray tracing
which is on and is beautiful
my gosh and if you for the chat bot
um patrick just put it there but um
exclamation point g-force
then uh look we've brought
you will get more information about the
sink
oh i didn't realize i was crouched the
whole time well we should deal with it
shouldn't we
i don't feel like this cover is is as
efficient as
v maybe thinks it is you know
come on pick your head up go away
like i'm definitely not hiding from this
dude i'm going to run up and hit him i'm
going to run up and hit him can i do
that
oh not as strong as i hoped
which is also a thing that's cool about
the tutorials is uh
or the other way the game scales in
general is um
you actually are actively like it's
harder to aim until you start
improving um you basically level up your
abilities with certain weapons
notice that tweaked the course i am
playing at 60 fps
um the stream i just don't think is and
i'm actually not positive
but i have had uh basically because i
had to get the game so very very
late where the update was concerned i
wasn't really able to play with um
my output settings as much as i should
have we are streaming at
4 000 a second
yeah and because i have any graphics
card i'm like completely not used to
these settings either
so i wasn't able to really play with
that as much as i would have liked
basically
um but i am playing in well i actually
put it to 60 so
okay
oh okay and then we we
scan
you just want me to scan this too okay
hazards are highlighted in red hackable
objects i realize that i'm over that
menu
that's my bad um objects useful
otherwise i highlighted blue do we have
anything highlighted blue
okay
this training module will teach you how
to apply
i like t-bug so much i think she's so
cool
jesus corpo speaking uh yeah youtube
chat does not have commands the commands
are on
on twitch um
okay kkk i technically do have a
streaming pc but i've never set it up
um i mean i have a spare pc i'll call it
a short piece work a little hack magic
on the screen to distract the guard
okay i don't have a lot of space but i
do have two pcs
use the tv screen gotcha
this is very watchdogs so we want to do
this one
interesting
and that's just on a timer
uh i imagine this is like mad
upgradeable what is this
targeting tagging is what you just told
me to do
os tagging with the cyberdeck installed
your scanner provides an additional
interface for selecting quick hacks and
their targets use distract enemies yeah
i did that
navigate the list of quick acts yes we
have done it come on buddy breach buddy
come on
you got it you eddie bit it now bud
i think that i am going to play with
hacking a little bit like
not too much but um so now
target is under effect of quick hack
trash style over substance
cool you want to take him down
good now take him out quietly
all right all yours take them out
choke them out good day sir i said good
day behind any trace of your handiwork
especially the dead kind now pick up the
body and hide it somewhere
why and then i think there are little
bins
okay
beautiful
okay now try to take him down in one
slick move
that's neat good stuff i like it
we like
i it saw one of the ones type pierce
know a lot will not be your girlfriend
well i don't know who asked depends
who's asking
um max j i'm not trying to find myself
in this stream
um i definitely i'll know when i'm able
to find myself in the game
um because you will get like a ping and
i know what my chest
i know what my quest is so uh
i'll record it for sure when i find
myself for the first time
uh execute a camera control quick hack
well that was much faster more advanced
quick hacks allow you to use the
environmental enemies to your advantage
okay
breach protocol can use network-wide
effects
okay
i've done this before but i don't
remember
how um is it that i have to pick a line
that has all of them or something
i don't remember how i did it
just select i feel like it was something
about
and then it would be bd from there and
then 55 from that yeah it's that's they
have to
that gets way more complicated for the
record way more difficult
and now we would like to that's messed
up
really gonna do that to this dude
i'm gonna take a while that is super
messed up though
scan results robot affiliation arasaka
week two
two ram approximately okay
cool
oh if you close that menu it goes faster
you should pay attention to that see
that's that's messed up
i i really just did that to him through
a camera through the camera just needed
to shut your brain down and follow
orders
in true militech fashion under
not too shabby militech's algorithms
shabby okay i think you can keep going
but i'm gonna
leave before you finish up dealt out now
yeah
but remember the street's not going to
give you any hints or second chances
that's cool
no no i'm good i'm good i would like to
leave
need a handwritten invite good day
we'll figure it out i play video games
so not bad huh now we can get down to
biz
can you find kochibe in the game i don't
know anything about that
will kako give you any tips and tricks
for the job
i'm not your mother just do what i pay
you for
it's easy work sure
let's do this
[Music]
you just crash we did we just crashed i
was like what was that noise how did
where did that come from
very strange hopefully
that's saved okay
i sure hope so buddy yeah
okay try again
uh what time is it oh my god today's
gonna suck
it's gonna be so rough it's
five i have a full work day man
um task manager
[Music]
okay is that the only crash
uh it's the only crash in the stream yet
but it might happen again
um this is what happened last time
um which is a real bummer
let me see what i can do
do do do
i hope that it works
no why are you spamming turn off gog
overlay
oh thank you for the heads up did other
people have that issue
um okay i can try that
settings and
gog
and the interface probably no
game features that's what it is um and
then it's overly okay
thank you i appreciate that yeah for the
record this doesn't have the day one
patch
just so everyone knows obviously i've
said it before but uh
it is very much worth noting um i'm
effectively playing
um i don't i don't want to use the
terminology
beta in case i'm wrong but i did have to
opt into the beta program
to play it so um
i did have to opt into a separate build
and then when the game's actually out i
could swap over to the build that
everyone else would play that does seem
to have fixed it maybe it is just like a
a very specific bug with the with
geogebra so thank you guys i appreciate
that
i mean i could turn rtx off but why
would i want to do that
i can't play the game full screen mr
duco or you guys will not be able to see
it
because i have a super ultra wide
monitor not just ultra wide
super ultra wide lottery rounded out to
a solid and sky
yeah i can't stream with most of the
settings that i would like to stream
with sadly
uh because yeah it doesn't it doesn't
work that way you know the only platform
it did work on
mixer i could play in super ultrawide on
my beautiful super ultrawide monitor
beautiful but
no other um platform allows that aspect
ratio
so that is a thing hey everyone
feels great to have you back um fulvius
i'm on 1080 um which is also for
streaming purposes
what was the other part of your question
though what fps you are getting
um it's currently i think i set it to
wait we just jumped ahead for scientific
research
quite honestly it's quite the power move
i'm not sure
um i forgot what i'm saying i had it
set to cap at 70. i think hq we are not
back at the start
i am so sorry certainly not back at the
start oh okay it's cool the rhythms put
you on a decent run
that checks out got additional modules
if you want to hone any other skills
before you finish up but remember
yeah i don't want to do it you do not
care need a handwritten invite
i am talking about the fps yes correct
you're right i am yes
crash was scripted it's just super
matter
okay let's go let's do this
this way
like i don't know why i'm so shook by
how pretty it is
again this is also my first time playing
on this new graphics card
so it's like probably me reacting in
real time to
having a new graphics card uh
apartments do you want me to talk to you
maybe i have played this maybe this is
the end of the problem don't remember
targets sandra dorsett targets no okay
this is the platform
target could have possibly flatlined
already not sure you're in time
we're in time bug we sure you're on
phones but
that'll make you any less part of this
squad squad
charming
thank you shia my uh o'shea my coffee's
good thank you i appreciate that
are we doing it did we do it ah
i had to press a thing it was like this
game doesn't have loading screens like
that there's no way
it's an rpg ladies and gentlemen gotta
get your luton in
i don't make the rules
looking for 1237. target should be
inside but i got zero i don't even know
what i'm picking up fingers crossed it's
not too late
so you i hate this life or death [__]
hurry
you just leaving dark chocolate out here
i don't mind if i do
try hacking the door think you can trip
it on your own v
but first i would like to look around
because that's what i do
and pick up all of the loot
oh it got real dark out here huh
it got so dark so fast
it's a good-looking hallway it's a lot
bigger than it
needs to be
no profile yeah we'll try
we'll try but dialysis hasn't [__]
changed
is that her
i have looting to do jackie give me a
second it's like you've never played an
rpg before
i gotta pick up all of this euro dollars
i'm glad i picked that up what are you
jackie idiot ooh
well i don't know why that's happened
but it's concerning
that's not great
okay oh this is heaven
no it's not sandra dorset's protected
under echelon 2 corporal immunity
it's the one on the ball top shelf this
one's packing black market zeta tech
repros
just like rip stuff back alley fix ups
not our lucky girl
geez let's keep looking okay
i could use hacks
unnecessary but
i'm gonna like do as much of it
non-lethal as i can get away with is
basically my plan
um obviously i'm not gonna get through
very much
i think i'm not gonna try super hard oh
physics bro
how do we feel about these physics
[Music]
i love a dull scalpel for me are you
kidding me
that's how fast we went from i'm gonna
try to um
not do it i just didn't think he'd be
looking in this direction
oh that's jackie that's jackie sorry
mate i'm sorry mate
just didn't you know just so it's just
so quick just so quick
oh that's right you can choose to kill
them or not to kill them i should have
chosen not to kill him
okay okay
i don't want to hit jackie though i'm
sure i can't hurt him but he don't walk
in front of me
what are you doing
hey hang on i'm trying to do something
excuse me i don't know where you are but
i was trying to pick up his gun that's
rude you can't do that when i'm trying
to learn
okay i want this one i was trying maybe
we just do it
oh i didn't even see who did that
but i didn't want to know what would
happen when i would die
and how long this takes to load and we
can reapproach this
completely is to play it
that was three seconds my account's
right that was literally three seconds
you'd love to see it um yeah the thing
about that dude is that i didn't even
need to distract him because he was
never going to hear me and then we're
going to reapproach this
and try not to get spotted immediately
see if i can use my hacks
i definitely do need to change the
control sensitivity but
i said that i wouldn't play with
settings anymore okay okay
we're not gonna [__] this up this time
jackie excuse me while i get my doll
scalpel
on your toes
is there anything in here
it's just that one dude not helpful not
terribly helpful
i'd love to
reboot optics
short circuit let's do that
[Music]
oh
what happened to him did he just like
glitch for a second is that what it did
[Music]
still facing me i can't do anything when
you looking right at me bud
um i can distract you with that and then
hopefully jackie helps
too many of them in this room is my
consent
this can't it can't it can't work
i'm sure it can but i feel like it would
take me a long time
okay now i can do this without being
killed
you do it did we do it did i pick up his
weapon
clean it out
[Applause]
yeah i really wanted to pick up his
shotgun
what are these guns floating in the air
for is that you jackie
oh
one more and i think that's it oh no
that's right
that's scripted i believe okay i'm just
gonna steal everybody's [__]
again it's an rpg
and then i will find out how much of it
is complete junk
hmm
listen i love an
i rpg no idea what i want to do with any
of this stuff um not that i can't do
anything yet but i think that it just
this is an example of a it just leveled
up my handguns because i'm using them
she's too lazy to use mouse and keyboard
what
what are you serious
um no it's just that uh
from every demo i played they basically
recommend it
here we go uh controller so i
am doing that because it seems like
what cdp i wanted people to do from my
perception
this looks pretty but
i don't like any of my clothes we need
to change all of this
the shoes are cool though
level requirements um all right
you got this do i
more stuff
i will take
i it this dude can shoot through walls
nice one jackie
i don't see any movement on the sensors
that's uh the climbing feels real smooth
[__] where the hell is our target that
was a lot easier than i expected if i'm
being completely honest
with that big dude it was it was good it
was good we did good
i mean come on you know
i will take you for a grenade
yeah cool cool cool
this is the part where we put it if i
remember correctly
look like even like the water lines on
that are you kidding me
i feel like this is technically like our
first actual outdoor view of night city
okay
i feel like i have so much reading to do
i do i i'm gonna do it but i won't make
you guys watch that
i'm gonna make this a long playthrough
got a lot of good stuff and from
zetatech
use his bio signature but we ordered a
jailbreak militech lock on sites
when i read this gunk got it arasaka
hormone regulator no bio signature and
some other little curiosities optics
actuator
and cosmetic real skin i feel like
that's how she talks at least
i feel like that's how she inflects uh
cool
also i really hope that the word that i
just said isn't an offensive slur
it could be and i just never heard the
word before
that would be a huge bubble i genuinely
don't know
okay
i think i got her got her target yeah
what up
i can't not look at it and now you can
all see me find out
yeah will i get in trouble for streaming
this on twitch i want right
sandra dorsett nc570442
trauma team platinum platinum [__]
drama should have swooped in if she
sneezed close everyone is let those
check out
unless you linger on it unnecessarily
you know me
scott muncher's hack huh got an idea
check her neural cord
find a shard yeah bullet that'll be
what's beautiful
is that even safe can't we just get her
out of here
we found her still breathing can't lose
her we need that by amon working
checking for hemorrhages whatever
find that shard and yank it okay
found the shard removing now check the
biomass
anything changing sandra if you are
conscious
assume recovery position now an
emergency evacuation unit has been
dispatched and is due to arrive and you
break the water droplets in 180 seconds
trauma will be here in three minutes
your premium plan will cover 90
of the projected costs of your rescue
and treatment
i just think this looks so good let's
get her off that ice
okay
i like that that if i looked at jackie i
could interact with him or otherwise he
just
he's flatlining yeah
v need to know what's going on jackie
air hypo [__] this is bad
catch chica
i'm pretty sure i've seen this before i
just forget that fast oh you stabbed her
right in the chest oh [__] it worked
get her outside okay hey
i wanted to see if movement would
interfere with the jiggle physics that
it actually
doesn't seem to that much
all right then they show up no that's
right you gotta place it really
[Music]
specifically
i'd love to
five steps back now
tt 133 to control patient nsc 570442
secure
stimulus being administered cool jobs
done thanks guys appreciate it
i probably would play this game and it
looks like this
billy eilish
we did it bro and i think i get to go to
my apartment now
elevator gets us to the garage directly
but have i looted everything jackie
you don't understand what it's like i
think i have to
see you in the near future listen
i got this thing mind if i borrow your
wheels
huh sure i got a date with misty but i
can't take the metro how they're gonna
look for me excuse me won't leave you
hanging jack
but don't get used to it
thank you i had a burger in a long time
how about i drive you home man
she's all yours i'm beat as it is
oh almost forgot she'll get wakako in
the hollow
tell her the job's done that's gonna be
[Music]
tea bug oh no it wasn't
you want me to call wakako
her
i like her a lot too
uh i did not put on an accent for my
character in the game
no i absolutely well
drama team took over i'm doing an
australian accent which is funny because
i actually think that i can't act
when it's my natural voice but i think i
can if i'm doing an accent
but they wanted my natural voice so if
the acting's bad i don't know why that
barrier is there
i think it's because my brain has
the district trouble separating it from
just being me whereas when i'm doing an
accent
i'm immediately a character yes maybe
it's something that i need to
to work for sure but i i distinctly
think it's a problem uh so i don't know
how it's going to turn out
but this full american
thing recently i'm driving where i like
i was happy with my performance
these are cool um
i want to put them away yeah
um but i don't know what i sound like in
this yet so
we'll find out but i suspect it's
probably bad because i can't do
i can't do uh australian
or i could do australian is the thing i
can't do my own voice that's what i have
trouble with oh it's a song from the
night city wise
legends are born
this uh won't be a dmca issue because
this is made for the song
made for the game um you're locking down
watson
[Music]
my brain's having trouble and that i
feel like i've seen all these negative
hot takes about this game this week
i've not read any reviews to be fair i
intentionally didn't read any
um and of course i'm super biased always
owning that never gonna hide any of that
but i'm like damn it looks so good
though
it's like i feel like i have not seen
enough like
hot takes of praise on my twitter
timeline um which is maybe because i
think this game has an issue of
perception
in that everyone always expected it to
be very good
and so people aren't shouting the things
that they like but i like i feel like
the city was
fantastic like i'm super impressed with
the way that it looks but again it's
also the oh the driver right yeah that
makes sense but
um definitely reacting to this
beautiful sturdy 80 thanks to nvidia
exclamation mark geforce i'm a bad
streamer and then i don't know the
terminologies for that correctly and
literally just set up a chatbot today
but i imagine that's what you say is it
command command g4 so that is that the
speakers
i don't think i mean sure people have
been complaining about the game on
youtube or whatever
to put traffic but more what i'm saying
is like my twitter timeline is full of
journalists
again super biased i could just like not
know what i'm talking about like i could
just not be getting through the filter
but i'm like
stunning it's weird to not have seen
more takes along the lines of this game
is stunning but maybe it's because
everyone already expected that because
this game's been so hot
but i also supervised we ran into you
rice is okay just own your buyers what
is it that makes me so special
a heart of gold because only somebody
with
a heart of gold can understand just how
much i need to get back to my
she's very wet look at her face
i also gotta be worried i think i played
this part
i mean in the preview
misconception okay uh you don't get into
that field unless you really like videos
stable in my affections
and don't assume me you get it
i cannot wait to play this ultra wide
it's going to blow my mind
feel good
[Music]
it doesn't
they had it coming
i'm just thinking about the character
creative thing with the hair and then i
was like it's entirely possible that
they just had that hair and they mapped
the most likely one to me but i don't
think that's the case
how likely to make it back to hayward
because i sent them those pictures like
wherever it goes
oh yeah anyway anyway
can you have more than one safe i
believe you can
can i show the map please i can't
eventually yeah um we're not even
technically in the game being open yet
uh it'll happen after i go to v's
apartment and then come back out
and i am gonna try and go to sleep for a
couple hours before i have to get up for
a full work day
and i might stream it again tonight i do
have a really big day today and tomorrow
the
game awards tomorrow it's a whole thing
um i will but i was supposed to do a
charity stream on on sunday and wasn't
able to because of
uh scheduling [__] um
i'm gonna walk around i'm gonna walk
around because that's what i wanna do
um so i might i might try and uh do one
tonight
it's supposed to be for feeding america
was what i was intending to do i believe
um but we'll see how i feel because i
don't want to
die before the game awards and all that
hibernation
implants tomorrow miners were able to
survive without access to food and fresh
water
for two weeks good
a runner i know has something you could
probably
our father use heaven so the game is now
officially the same
um it has been for a while
which promotes the use of cybernetic i
appreciate that man of steel thank you
so remember what you said in your video
elana you want us to remind you to work
less this is that
you're right i should not stream this
game tonight you are absolutely right
i should sleep if i got up at
2 30 to stream it and then i have to get
up at six tomorrow
and work a full-time job
but i want to it's the problem but
you're right look at this
game i
my brain is confused by why i haven't
seen
hot takes on my twitter timeline
about the environments but again
i'm worried that that is just my brain
melting at
me having ray tracing for the first time
this is uh the first game i've played on
my
technical second i did do a little test
but not really um on my 3080 so
which by the way the stream is sponsored
by a video thank you nvidia if you use
the command g-force it's in the
in the in the title on the twitch
um you'll get info
about the thing yeah we have we have
retracing on and
dlss on um
oh yeah you can watch tv
they seem to put a lot of work into this
and they stuff pay any price in exchange
for a chance
of this so-called immortality well
that is true that arasaka corp has
specifically limited
access to the relic in got a lot to
learn
that's all i'm saying are the apartments
different for each of the life paths
eight-bit antichrist no
they are the same is that the weather to
the right
um yeah i think it actually is you know
i think that you can see uh
info about um
the outdoors and whatever
cool thing about the city it is rendered
in real time
um which it she knows every time
for anyone who doesn't know means that
those cars that you see right there if i
were to
somehow teleport there or walk outside
and go there they're actually there
they are actually where they are in the
world
um if i were to walk outside that would
be scrolled
exactly to where it should be it's not
just a fake image
what is mac and cheesus and can i go
there
um a fake image of the city i think
that's super impressive
why are you not why are you guest on
your own pc you weird
dude you got any
any like cute i've been attacked
no oh my gosh who can i call for help
about this
we need to hit scan now you want my
social security number okay
do not click on any emails with ads for
a penis enlargement nano gel this is a
scam
error sex you say
why is penis always spelled differently
an interesting choice
i'm really out here in a video game
release
reading other people's spam
[Laughter]
okay
oh dick and whiskey don't mind if i do
all right i reckon my inventory is full
of trash right now
that's right you can take a shower
hello love your hair looks atrocious in
this mirror
did you do it did you smile i don't know
that you did
there's the smile and it's creepy
no i'm uncomfortable uh okay
what kind of stuff you got
is that protein powder shaving cream
alcohol really got it all
yes did you not even take your clothes
off
it's fine
what system am i playing this on uh that
would be
pc my dude with my new
a 30 80. i like this room a lot
all safe houses and vehicles it says for
example if you store something in your
car trunk you'll be able to access it
from your cool way
and this is where i think we can also do
crafting
which right now i have very little
understanding of
i mean
you know what i'm saying
so this is all gonna be stuff that i
picked up
movie's favorite top i didn't like the
way she was dressed actually
hang on hang on how can i hang out this
is my inventory i took it out of my
inventory we want to put it back
we want to put it back boots
these no mad shoes i like the sneakers
better
no
i do like that
okay
you tell me i have a katana already
um
so we're gonna put that
away i guess this is
just me changing my inventory right now
not actually um
i'll sell it all i'm just gonna keep it
and then we'll just take it to a vendor
and set up sell it all
i like the menu i don't know if people
like even really remember because we
have this like warped
remember remembery this is what happens
when you stream at 5am
um this warped memory of the witcher 3
in a lot of cases which for the record i
think is the best game of the last
console generation
uh but it did have issues on launch
um it it had a i think a terrible
inventory system
um geralt still sort of walks like a
tank
um there are other reasons that we
remember that game incredibly fondly
i love the writing in which i think some
of those quests are so good but uh
i am judging v a lot why did you sleep
like that
what you just said is a lie he said do
you see the game start review about the
game
i did not actually read it i don't
really read any reviews and then he said
the journalist did not even play the
game
she played the game for 50 hours don't
let the internet lie to you
about that that is not true and it sucks
to see
false narratives get carried away when
it is not accurate
i think i might have caught something
when i jacked into that corpose biomine
then a neurovirus or i need to see vic
let him tell me what's got my head
reeling at my stomach churning
okay let me take you i brought you a
ride
on some threads maybe downstairs i would
love to
uh so i just took all this stuff but
what i want to do is actually get
changed she's probably gonna be in here
i agree matthew why was v sleeping that
way it don't make sense so
your backpack
what i want to do is like like change
what i'm wearing i'm unclear on where to
do that
would that be in character maybe
no um oh hey here's the map for the
people who are asking to see the map
i don't know how far out it goes or any
of that
if there's a fog of war type thing
and it's also like when i first played
this game with the preview
uh people kept being like how big is the
map
it's so hard to give people an
indication of map size
uh d.o.d.o i have not played the game
this is my first time playing it aside
from again that preview that i mentioned
so
um there was a time jump for the person
who asked why v suddenly has an
apartment there was a
a uh cut scene that like showed you
being introduced to night city that was
a
uh time job i have not met my npc i
probably won't do that
i agree dave i strongly agree okay
um what am i trying to figure out how to
change what i
am wearing
that's interesting i can skip time
um is there because i just took a bunch
of stuff
but i'm not sure if i'm just like being
stupid because i'm tired
like this seems like a place where i
would change my clothes
eh why did your titties just twitch well
that just happened
it's not there it's not there
just click inventory did i not do that
have i not
done that no you're right no i
i had not done it correctly you're 100
right and then it's just going to be
through here
you're absolutely right
are you me i guess it's kind of what i'm
wearing um
that's a lot more garish than i thought
it would be
it's a bit much
no that looks like a wife beater we're
gonna go with this one
yeah kind of like that
he's casual
uh i feel like we're gonna just do some
holsters you real you're a real nathan
drake
out here love and then
milady why did it change your hair
changes the hairstyle completely that's
actually a
pretty good way to customize the hair um
but i hate you now so
so no can we just unequip it yeah
pants oh yeah
absolutely ridiculous
i don't like any of it
i would wear those though yeah i would
wear those
special i doubt i have a clothing set no
i don't okay the shoes
we already like let's have a look shall
we
no it's the sex i just don't know how i
feel about this though
no you just you just look too trashy
it's not
maybe we just get rid of this and that
will make me like it more
you look mad chill you know
okay cool let's go i have a lot of stuff
that i can sell
that's a shiny top
hey v regina jones hey regina if you're
looking for work in watson
give me a call how did you find me how'd
you even know my name
i know where to gather my intel could
even call me a collector i'm not on a
call
cell well that's what we wanted in it
cool that that's so easy to find um cell
junk
yeah and then
we just make some money we just come out
here we just make some money um
joshua i'm i would say i've been playing
slowly
for the record because i'm like actually
making effort to look around and stuff
so i've been streaming for an hour and
56 minutes
um which i feel like probably translates
to an hour and a half
maybe
uh crash plays i'm not playing on low
settings my settings are not low
um i believe my stream is 30 frames a
second
uh that's kind of just because of the
way that i had to set it up my obs
just re-defaulted everything and
everything came together very last
minute so
um that is
just the reality of the way this came
together
okay
cool oh you can buy stuff back
i'm gonna get rid of those i'm gonna
keep that we'll get rid of i don't want
to get rid of that oh that's not what i
thought it was okay
definitely keeping the trilby who are
you kidding
i don't need any of this but i don't
like those are worth a lot
but they do give you armor right that's
like 9.99 i'm not getting rid of it
okay i feel like i should it's not the
time it's just not the time to be doing
that [__] ncpd
open up we got a call we're here to help
we know you're in there but soak in that
sun while you can
you really out here wearing heels on the
job
as we head into the weekend you see me
doing that i respect it though
it's so incredibly dread so for the
record v is supposed to live in like
a bad area um
when danger lurks
this is not supposed to be an ideal
place to live even though
did i do something wrong
don't forget um her apartment's actually
like super nice in my opinion
i should go to sleep and i will soon
come on why is the stream quality trash
that is going to be youtube compression
my friend
um it will look better on twitch
mr white is here
yeah i'm down i have to do how you like
my new punching bag
just gave me a next-gen ass whooping he
did
next round to see how he handles the
likes of me
so how about it cool with it yeah let's
do it because i actually never tried it
let's do this i've not tried millie um
but it's a thing that i wasn't sure
looked great so
if this can be dangerous in fist fights
you can use them to both strike your
enemies and block their attacks
cool
did that just say oh obviously that's
done though
um that felt better than i expected it
to
what have we got on sale oh yeah only
top shelf gear
i need to stop i need i need to stop i
need to not do this
i mentioned something about fighting i'm
not far enough in
to comprehend the sales system yet
you've got sharpness one step at a time
you can go far especially if you get
chipped
these fights let's just say they aren't
legal but very lucid
we predict for who you or me
both of us i get a small piece i'm down
yes sounds fair fight club baby
good instinct fights happen in different
parts of the city
you are right rocket i do need to go to
sleep soon and starts
i'm gonna get outside and then i'm gonna
start the stream managed to drop because
i
still have a full white chance to fight
in the ground for now
is that all clear sounds great crystal
good
oh except you won't be setting foot
outside or once
not yet you can start
that checks out i believe in you
for the record just in case it's not
totally clear for some reason when i'm
hitting b that's what's doing that on
the screen is because it's possible
a fitting way to have that mechanic
nice after every shot i came in the
wrong way
but he reacted to it neat
hey let's have a look
he has a free thing to give me doesn't
he
that's the point of this
uh so a lot of these are locked because
of my street cred am i reading that
correctly
does look nice i thought that he did
have something for you to give me
um is this max settings more or less
it is 5 50 am is it
which card is this game running on um
i'm not entirely sure what you mean by
that but i am playing on
a 3080 this stream
it's once in my nvidia
that locked you to money well you can
also have things locked due to street
cred
um i feel like because i'm so tired i'm
not even reading correctly
but i know that this man has something
free to give
me
it's a pistol is it this one
yeah there it is cool
an iconic item along with a set of
crafting specs you can use these to
craft better quality versions of this
suite when a new version of an iconic
item is crafted the original item was
destroyed
awesome thanks a lot very cool very
the one cool and uh we're gonna go
downstairs
what was that it's time for going to my
own hands
oh i can see my feet confirmed i really
do like these pants though
it's a big ass building
i have a nicola can i think i do yeah
they gave it to me on e3 a couple years
ago the festival is the arasaka
corporation
and thank you fighting development
thank you ricardo i genuinely appreciate
the amount of you that i like
go to sleep um
it's actually very nice
i appreciate it it's like i appreciate
that you
care because i am tired that i did
have to start late because of an update
and i do have a full day of work ahead
of me so thank you
it means a lot uh is this post launch
patch
it is not no
you writing them up so here's what i
just wanted to show you guys before i
finish the stream we won't talk to
jackie just yet
i basically just wanted to show you
night city
um
i feel like it's quite densely populated
there's lots going on it's colorful
like i think this game was really
impressive um that's the thing that i
feel like i've been saying from the jump
is that like
night city itself is such an impressive
part of this game
and that's that's the thing that i keep
being like i'm so surprised people
aren't
like people aren't talking about it more
that should have happened to be fair i
deserved that
i don't know why i didn't consider that
that would happen
but yeah this is this is uh this
particular district obviously
um they vary really significantly
oh you mad all right
and when what happens if i follow
someone let's follow yusuf with the sore
arm
just to see what happens yeah
are you gonna
you okay what you uh
lost your way and does that have that
and what are you doing this look at look
at what
very rude so he did not walk very far
find someone else hey where are you
going
she can't because they've created a
traffic jam hola
you're just gonna take a seat well if
that was the ai recognizing that she
couldn't walk that way and thus it made
her walk
over and sit i'm actually quite
impressed by that where did you pull
that from there
whoa are you okay
that's a zombie that's what the is the
plot twist of this game this is actually
gonna be a zombie outbreak
anyway um i
think the city looks great genuinely
like i'm
i think night city is awesome
i keep for whatever reason and i don't
know what it is it has to be that like
i'm not used to being run over in video
games like i feel like in gta just cross
the street but people stop for you
so being hit by cars is something i keep
not
expecting to happen
ah amazing then if i just it's telling
me to wait okay i'm waiting i'm waiting
can i go yet is there a button to press
no he's still waiting
all right okay you better give me the
correct instructions if you say wait
this whole time
what are the traffic rules okay there it
should change right
no that one's still red what are we
waiting for are you gonna change
oh that's floating wait wait did it
change
cool
that's the city that's the city have i
started my sony job yet yes
over a month ago wow okay jeez
um
so yeah this is uh this is the city
everyone
it looks wonderful i feel like i'm like
maybe having
some frame rate drops here but
i'm also too tired to see there's lots
going on
super densely packed i feel like there
is
basically the right amount of pedestrian
traffic for
la which is what the city's modeled off
of obviously it would be nothing
compared to like a san francisco um
but la doesn't ever have a tremendous
amount i'm gonna get hit by a cargo
a tremendous amount of pedestrian
traffic but it's not like it's
it's none you know but anyway yeah i
gotta try not to even
assess this game critically i am in it
it's hard for me to just not speak my
opinions out loud
um but obviously yeah tons of bias i'm
owning all of the bias
i am literally a paid chill
in this case literally they paid me
uh to be in the game so yeah i'm gonna
stop so i can sleep
before i have to get up for work to make
a video game
you know how it is
um frame rate overall process pro star i
just wanted to move away from the music
seems great game's gorgeous uh had a
crash during the stream obviously um
a couple of things like not connected to
things floating objects
but nothing other than that so far so
thank you all for watching
i have not met my npc yet
i will make sure i record that when i do
it for sure
um because that's going to be pretty
surreal for me i think
but otherwise yeah the stream is
sponsored by nvidia
i will leave it up everywhere um they
sent me the 3080. so this is my first
time
what you actually got in this stream was
olana having ray tracing on this
beautiful
monitor that i have for the first time
ever which was like a lot of what was
blowing my mind it's
amazing and uh
if i am up to it i probably shouldn't i
might stream some more tonight and we'll
raise some money
charity at the same time um but i really
shouldn't
this be such a busy week so thank you
all for watching
i'm gonna sleep for about three hours
um yeah
we'll see you guys next time let us
end the thing